there's a text message where johnny
promises
total global humiliation for you
do you feel like that came true
i know he promised it
i testified to this
i'm not
a good victim i get it i'm not a likable
victim i'm not a perfect victim
but
i
when i testified i asked the jury to
just see me
as human and hear
his own words
which is a promise to do this it feels
as though he has
amber heard reflecting on the ripple
effects of her tumultuous trial with
johnny depp
having been found liable are you nervous
as we are here today about
what you can say now
of course
i took for granted
what i assumed was my right to speak
do you feel like you could be sued again
by him for defamation i'm scared that
no matter what i do
no matter what i say or how i say it
every step that i take
will present another opportunity
for
this sort of uh silencing
which is what i guess a defamation
lawsuit is meant to do it's meant to
take your voice
but amber is still speaking just days
after a jury stunned many and found the
actress defame depp in an op-ed where
she said she was a public figure
representing domestic abuse
the piece which never mentioned depp by
name was published two years after the
couple announced they had settled their
divorce
life had seemingly moved on and you
decide to write an op-ed
why did you do that because op-ed wasn't
about
my relationship with johnny but it
alluded to him it was unmistakable
you know what the op-ed was about was um
you know me loaning my voice to bigger
cultural conversation that we were
having at the time did you worry gosh
i'd love to be a person weighing in on
these cultural issues but that's going
to stir this all up again i obviously
knew it was important for me not to make
it
about him
or to
do anything like to fame him i had
lawyers teams of lawyers
review
all the drafts of this when you wrote
this op-ed it was the height of me too
legions of powerful men
being
canceled losing their jobs
did you want that to happen to johnny
depp
of course not
of course not it wasn't about him
but the op-ed and the abuse alleged was
at the heart of the six-week trial just
pulls his arm back with the phone and
throws it at my face
hit me
right in my it felt like my eye
heard testified that the final straw
came after a violent fight in may 2016.
six days later she filed for a
restraining order cameras capturing her
as she left the courthouse
but depp's lawyers convinced the jury
heard was lying about the abuse police
who responded to the 2016 incident
testified during the trial that they
didn't see any injuries and that hurd
declined to file charges this was a hoax
is according to his team
why didn't i cooperate with the police
as i've testified before and i will
stand by until my dying day i didn't
want to cooperate with them i didn't
want this to be out i didn't want this
to be known i didn't
want to cooperate with them because i
didn't want this to be i didn't want to
get him in trouble if it was a host i
could have done that but five days later
you went to court and it came out five
days later i made the decision
to stand up for myself and protect
myself you can't get a restraining order
in private which of course i didn't
understand the night when the cops were
called
an employee of tmz testified at court
and said that tmz was tipped off about
when you were going to be going to the
courthouse and on what side of your face
bruises would be apparent did you tip
off tmz i was going to say he certainly
didn't get tipped off by me or anyone in
my mind you know
why would they no you ask no one to do
that as i testified to before
had nothing to do with me they're
different incidents that you testified
to and the depth legal team would put up
pictures of you publicly
right after that or in the days
following and saying
that why are there no no bruises again
it's that thing if you have bruising if
you have injuries it's fake if you don't
have any then it's then you weren't
injured you had promised to donate the
seven million dollars of your divorce
settlement to charity it was revealed at
trial that
you haven't done so yet however they
played a tape where you stayed on the
air that you have donated it do you
think that raised questions as to your
credibility with the jury
i made a pledge
and
that pledge
is made over time by its nature and you
say i donated
you know that everybody thinks that
you've donated it not that you've
pledged it so
for the jurors sitting there
do you think they felt like that was you
getting caught in a lie i i don't know
because so much of the
i feel like so much
of the trial was meant to
cast aspersions on who i am as a human
my credibility to call me a liar and in
every way you can and that was the trial
it was a credibility contest and that
was it this is another one of the
examples where if you pull back and you
think about it i shouldn't have to
donated it in an effort to be believed i
shouldn't have had to earmark the
entirety of that in order to have you
shouldn't have but once you said you did
right which is where it was intended
to go
heard says she still plans to honor that
pledge how do you see your future now
i get to be a mom
like
full time you know where i'm not having
to juggle
calls
with lawyers one day you may
want to tell your daughter about this or
have to tell your daughter
about everything that you've gone
through what would you
want to say
i think
no matter what it will mean something
i did the right thing
i
did everything i could
to stand up for myself and the truth
heard and depp's volatile relationship
lasted just four years depp confirming
his engagement to me on today in 2014.
congratulations thank you are you
excited yeah very
she's a wonderful girl and she's
she's sharp as a tag it's you know
wonderful you know uh
uh southern belle and um sweet as can be
and uh
and very good for me you know
on the first day of the trial you
issued a statement and part of the
statement said i still have love for
johnny
yes is that still true yes
after everything absolutely
absolutely
i love him
i loved him with all my heart
and i tried the best i could to make a
deeply broken relationship work
and
i couldn't